- [Mark] Oh yeah, I'm
gonna need a lot of this.
Oh yeah, I could eat a lot of that sauce.
(funky music)
Good morning everyone it's Mark Wiens
with Migrationology.com
in Barcelona, Spain.
Woke up this morning
and packed all the bags.
We are getting ready to
leave, but before we head out
we're gonna head downstairs
to have a quick breakfast.
This is exactly what I am looking for.
I could not leave Barcelona
without some more jamon,
one last breakfast dosage.
Oh, this is a pile of the jamon,
look at how beautiful it is.
It's so good.
And then, these are some
other types of Iberico pork.
This one is particularly
good, it's very lean.
This one, this type of
chorizo is also really good.
- [Woman] Good morning.
- [Mark] Good morning.
(mellow Hispanic music)
It's just wonderful, and
I also like this chorizo.
Just a hint of a spice to it.
(funky upbeat music)
That was a good breakfast and we just
checked out of Cotton House Hotel.
It's a really nice
boutique hotel in Barcelona
and it's in a really good location.
That was a very nice stay.
We're walking over to the metro
and heading to the airport.
(funky upbeat music)
45 minutes later we have
arrived at the airport.
It's about 8:30 am.
Barcelona has been fantastic.
This is really an amazing city to visit,
lots of delicious food and some amazing
architecture as well.
And, I love the cafe culture here.
But, we are catching a
flight with TAP Portugal
on our way to Lisbon.
(funky upbeat music)
We are somewhere in the
sky and we are flying
across, just across the Iberian Peninsula
from Barcelona to Lisbon, Portugal.
And, they just served us a little snack.
I almost thought it was
a egg on the bottom,
but I think that's bread, a
little open faced sandwich.
I think there are two
layers of meat on here.
And then, with rocket on the top,
there's something sweet on the top, too.
I ate that whole sandwich
and I was thinking
the whole time that it was turkey.
But now, that I think about it,
I think it was actually fish.
(funky upbeat music)
I just woke up, got a good nap in.
We should be landing in
Portugal in about 10 minutes.
(funky upbeat music)
- [Man On PA] Landing is on
track here in just one minute
Alberto Delgado Airport.
Please remain seated with
your seat belt fastened
until the seat fastened
sign is switched off.
- That was about an hour and half flight.
Welcome to Lisbon.
(funky upbeat music)
Bus number one will go
to Avenida de Libertad.
- [Woman] Yes, there's cab fare.
- We have decided to take
the bus into the city
because that's the most
direct, I think it will be
the easiest way.
And so, they have a stand outside.
This is for Aerobus, we're
taking bus number one.
I got this long receipt
that is our ticket.
(funky upbeat music)
That took a little while
because the traffic was heavy,
but we just got off our bus
stop at Avenida de Libertad.
And, our hotel should be
just across the street.
We are staying at the Fontecruz Lisboa,
which is another Hotel by Marriott.
And, this is in a very
lovely area of town.
Looks like a shopping street with a lot of
high end designer brands.
We checked in, but our room is not ready.
They said it's gonna be
ready in about an hour
so we're gonna hang out for a little bit
and do some research.
As we are waiting for our
room to finish being cleaned
we decided to take, they
offered us this welcome
plate of fruit and so we
decided to eat it now.
I think it's supposed to
be served in the room,
but I think this is a good
time to eat it right now.
Our mango, orange, kiwi, and well, kiwi.
I don't think I've had a
mango yet on this trip.
Mmm, that's a good mango.
Which one is it?
(mumbles)
Zero, five.
Yeah.
It's a little bit of a dark theme.
- [Woman] And with that
it's back to training.
- Okay, welcome to our hotel in Lisbon.
Before we do anything else let me give you
a quick tour of the hotel room.
This is the bathroom,
everything is kind of
a dark theme, toilet,
oh and a chest.
And then, out to the main bedroom.
It's a pretty spacious room.
Kind of has an antique feel to it,
but a dark theme.
A relax chair, whoa,
a full body mirror.
We are off now to walk around and explore
and hopefully find something to eat.
But, I wanted to just quickly share that
this is my first time to be in Portugal
and I'm really excited to be here
because I've been to a lot of countries
from Kenya and the east coast of Africa
to Sri Lanka to even
Thailand that have been,
oh that's a really loud motorcycle,
but I've been to so many
countries that have been
influenced by Portugal.
And also, the Portuguese are responsible
for distributing and for
bringing chilies from
South America to Asia.
Chilies being one of my
favorite foods in the world
so I'm excited to be here.
This tree lined avenue
is absolutely beautiful.
(funky upbeat music)
Ying and I were both
very hungry so we came
to this restaurant that's
very close to our hotel
and it's also very close
to a couple of attractions
that I wanna visit this afternoon.
So, we are stopping here for a quick lunch
and this restaurant is called Bonjardim.
Okay.
- [Waiter] And, pedi a pedi Okay.
- [Mark] Pedi a pedi okay.
Okay, thank you.
Ying and I decided to
each get a half a chicken
and so we got the
chicken, we got some rice,
and I also ordered a vegetable
spinach dish, as well.
I'll put this half a chicken,
put this onto my plate.
Oh yeah.
And, okay I just gotta taste this.
Let me just taste this immediately.
That is salty, a little bit
oily and then the chicken
is really, really soft.
But, what I really wanna
try here is the pedi a pedi
chili and this is quite
a like a oily chili sauce
with a little paint brush in it.
And, add on some of that sauce,
I'm not sure if, are you
supposed to touch it?
(cutlery clinks)
Just a little bit spicy but it has a sour
chili oil flavor to it.
I'm going to need a lot of this.
And, I wanna scoop out those seeds,
the seeds from the bottom.
Oh yeah, I could eat a lot of that sauce.
And then, this is come
kind of a rice fried with
I think it's chicken,
something from the chicken.
Maybe could it be the gizzard and liver
maybe fried with rice?
Oh, that's a good, that's
a nice ratio though.
Yeah, I'm not exactly sure what it is.
I saw it in, it said "Arroz
Brasilerio" I think on the menu.
Yeah, I think that's rice fried with liver
and maybe some other
organs, mostly liver I think
that gives the rice a creamy,
iron-y component to it.
And, also got some creamed spinach.
And, this is the dish that
I just saw on the menu
and I wanted to try.
Whoa, that is very pasty, whoa very pasty.
It's almost like dough.
Wow, that's very sticky and like,
its like a sticky whipped
cream almost of spinach.
And, it's very thick and dense.
You can taste the green spinach flavor.
It's a little bit salty, but it's mostly
just all about that
spinach and then a really
yeah like doughy, sticky texture to it.
Wow, this could be filling because
it's so densely sticky.
I think it's all right
to just brush you chicken
with the pedi pedi.
(funky upbeat music)
We finished with that
lunch, the chicken was good.
Felt great to eat an entire
half of chicken as well,
get that protein in the system.
We were both really hungry.
And, nice to sit out
here it's a great day.
The breeze in Lisbon is fantastic.
And also, I'm liking these
cobblestone streets in Lisbon.
Actually, I'm not sure
what type of stone they are
but they are so silky and so smooth
you can actually just scoot,
and you slide as well.
Right across from where we ate lunch
we are walking now over
to Ascensor da Gloria.
(funky upbeat music)
This is a Lisbon historical landmark
and originally the Gloria
Funicular opened in 1885,
but back then it worked
on, it was powered by
a water counter weight system.
And so, what's really awesome
is that the Gloria Funicular
is still open to the public for rides.
And, we are boarding now and
about to head up the hill.
We waited until the tram was pretty full.
It's pretty stuffed
right now and we are on
our way now up the hill.
(funky upbeat music)
That was a short, just
about three minute ride
but I think it's more about the history
of this funicular than
the actual transportation.
And, there were some nice
views of some beautiful
painted murals on the wall as well.
Okay, that was fun.
From the top of the
funicular there is a park
with a viewpoint, so gonna get a good,
hopefully a good panoramic
view of Lisbon from here.
(funky upbeat music)
A cool breeze, great views of Lisbon
and I'm glad we came here on our first day
actually just a couple hours
after we landed in Lisbon.
This gives me a good idea of the city
and some of the landmarks.
I can see the castle in the distance,
the ocean, yeah a nice viewpoint,
nice place to just hang out.
(funky upbeat music)
Ah.
No.
(Portuguese folk music)
Yes, hi I'm going on.
I am just stepping into
the church and it is
elaborate on the inside.
There is the main sanctuary,
which is a huge open space
but then on the sides there are all sorts
of different chapels and altars.
And then, you look up at that ceiling,
it is decorated and painted with a mural.
And then, while I'm walking on the floor
it is ancient looking marble.
The fourth chapel on the left hand side
is considered to be one
of the most expensive
chapels in the world.
It includes gold and
silver and lapis lazuli
and it was actually designed in Rome.
And then, in the back is
a Baroque style painting.
Just spent a few minutes walking around
Igreja de Sao Roque and this is a church,
a Jesuit church in Lisbon that dates back
to the 16th century.
It's known to have a very
simple facade on the outside
and look very simple on the outside,
but when you step inside
it's just full of gold.
It's elaborate, and it's
known for it's riches.
(tribal music)
Oh, look at that fish.
Oh, and there's lobster
in the window there, too.
Oh, I need to eat some
seafood very soon in Lisbon.
But, this is just an amazing city.
It has a wonderful artistic feel to it.
And, I'm loving the wind
and the views of the city.
We are in an area of town
now called Bairro Alto.
So, I think we're just
gonna walk around this area.
This is a fantastic area of Lisbon.
And, although it hasn't
been very long since lunch
I think we might try to have dinner
and then head back to the hotel.
(funky upbeat music)
We're just walking around leisurely,
not really looking for anything,
but I just found a cafe
that I wanted to check out
so I think now would be a perfect time
to have a quick cup of coffee.
(indistinct chatter)
I don't know if I should
feel the need to sit down.
I was originally just
gonna stand at the bar
and just have a quick cup of coffee,
but we decided to sit at this empty table.
This is a real legendary, a
historic coffee shop in Lisbon.
As soon as I could get the
attention of the waiter
I just ordered a coffee.
Hey, that is good coffee.
Mm, strong but smooth,
not too thick.
I might have to have one more.
These wooden chairs and tables are
absolute classics as well, and the mirrors
on the walls, the
decorations, the chandeliers.
Okay, I had to order another one.
Oh that's hot, really hot,
right out of the machine.
Oh, wonderful.
(indistinct chatter)
Those were two, well spent
Euros, two good cups of coffee.
This is a legendary, classic place.
(funky upbeat music)
It's a shower head.
- [Woman] The dishes come
one by one to the table,
and for two people I recommend
three dishes to share.
So, today we have house
dish is good mackerel tartar
with ginger, citrus,
(mumbles) tartar sauce
very fresh (mumbles).
If you like raw fish or sushi
we'll definitely try this one.
- We came to a restaurant
which is right in this area.
It's called Taberna da Rua das Flores
and this restaurant I didn't realize
at lunch time they serve
more of a Portuguese menu
and then at dinner it's kind of a modern
kind of modern style Portuguese food,
but it's really cozy little restaurant.
It's very friendly service
and you sense the passion
of the food in this place.
And so, they just have a daily set menu
which is according to season and according
to what ingredients are available.
Starting off with some
olives and I've already
had a couple of them.
Those are fantastic olives, salty and sour
and have a fantastic
texture to them as well.
They're like a little bit silkier
than other olives I've had.
The lighting in here is pretty dim
so I'm going to have to use my cellphone
to light up the food when I take a bite.
The first dish that we
got this one is a ceviche
of I think the fish is cr-oo-k,
with I'm not sure what's on
top, some kind of pickles
and then surrounded by sweet potato chips.
This looks fantastic.
Oh, oh no some of the chips just slid off.
Let me take a piece of the fish
and try to get some of that
pickle at the same time.
It's sour, those cubes of
raw fish are just slightly
cooked on the edges from that acidity.
And then, it has just a very light garnish
of cilantro maybe.
Oh man, yeah I love ceviche,
is just, or any type of fish
or raw fish is fantastic.
You can taste the freshness of the fish
and the quality and just how
beautiful the dish is as well.
I'm gonna grab some of these
little chips on the side.
They're crispy but they've soaked up
some of that lemon juice.
The next dish we have is
marlin and this has been,
I think, pan seared.
And then, it looks like
Thai sweet and sour sauce.
I think it's just seared on
the inside and a little bit
it might be a little
bit pink on the inside
which is why you need
to cut it with a knife.
And, that fish is extraordinary.
It's soft and buttery.
You can taste the different textures.
In the middle it's raw, but
then on the outside edges
it is cooked and it almost
has a chicken breast texture
to it on the inside, but
buttery all the way through.
They suggested that we have three dishes
between the two of us and
then they should be served
one dish by one dish.
So, we've had two dishes so far
and now we are on our third dish.
This is black pork and
they're little cubes
of pork which look
marvelous, little nuggets,
glistening nuggets and
then there are onions
on top and some cilantro
and a lemon wedge on top.
Let me just taste that piece right there.
It looks kind of crispy
and soft at the same time.
Wow.
Oh yeah, that is exactly correct.
It is crispy and soft at the same time.
Crispy on the edges, it's salty
and then because it is quite well marbled
with some fat mixed in it is so juicy.
And just when you bite down you get
that crispy caramelized pork edge
and then just that fatty juice.
Wow, that's insane.
Then, I love it with those
red onions, the cilantro.
I'm gonna squeeze on
a little bit of lemon.
Wow, that is a treat, a treat indeed.
That is insane.
Ying and I just finished with dinner
and I have to tell you
that when I was going to
this restaurant I was hoping to have
an authentic Portuguese dinner.
But, when got here then they said
that at lunch time they
serve Portuguese dishes
but at dinner time they
serve Portuguese ingredients
but with a modern twist and it turned out
to be an exceptionally good meal.
The ingredients were incredible.
The different dishes
that they put together
were simple but the ingredients
were outrageously good,
delicious food that was
kind of a trendy meal.
But, it was really, really good.
So, if you come for
lunch you can get more of
the Portuguese dishes but
at dinner it's a special
seasonal menu of the
ingredients they have.
I think this is the perfect
place to end today's volg.
Thank you all for watching.
Please remember to give
this video a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it and also
make sure you subscribe
for lots of more food
videos and I'll see you
on the next video.